don't have hard feelings against him is
just uh just how how things go right now
hey guys i'm lauren zima so I have been
wondering for weeks
when Bachelorette frontrunner Jordan
Rogers would finally address his
mysterious relationship with his famous
brother Aaron and Monday night he did it
here's how Jordan explains that he and
his brother Lou hang out all the time
without Aaron in fact that their whole
family spends a lot of time together
without Aaron me and Aaron don't really
have that much of a relationship it's
just kind of the way he's chosen to to
do life and I chose to stay close with
my family and my parents and my brother
and yeah that's just it's not ideal and
I love him and and now I can't imagine
what it's like to be in his shoes and
have the pressure he has and the demands
from people that he has so is it just me
or does it seem like George is kind of
throwing Aaron under the bus there it
sounds like Jordans side of things is
that Aaron is the one who chose not to
speak to their family where he says he
and Aaron don't speak at all and he also
hinted at some resentments that he has
frankly at every step of my life I was
just kind of disappointed and no matter
what I did it was never good enough for
a coach or for a teammate because I was
being compared to someone who did it the
best
yikes yikes yikes that is so awkward I'm
dying for Aaron to weigh out of this but
I want to know what you think whose side
are you on Jordans or earrings let me
know on Twitter